Pues a los cancilleres aquí reunidos
finalmente
están preparando han preparado
analistado ya el documento la
declaración de Santo Domingo que
firmarán mañana jefes de gobierno y los
jefes de Estados presentes aquí en
República Dominicana para esta Cumbre
iberoamericana y lo que ya se ha
constatado es que se firmará la carta
iberoamericana por los derechos
digitales también la carta
medioambiental iberoamericana así como
un plan de ruta crítico para atajar la
situación de inseguridad alimentaria que
afecta a la región Y es que recordemos
que según el último informe de la FAO el
40% más del 40% de hecho de la población
a latinoamericana vive bajo situación de
inseguridad moderada o leve inseguridad
alimentaria pero sin embargo se cae uno
de los Pilares de esta Cumbre que era la
petición de una nueva arquitectura
financiera para que los países de la
región pudieran acceder más fácilmente a
préstamos y a créditos internacionales
otra de las cuestiones que no está
explícitamente en este documento final
según hemos podido comprobar gracias a
un borrador al que hemos tenido acceso
Es que tampoco hay una mención
finalmente a la guerra en Ucrania Aunque
Sí una compromiso para trabajar para la
paz total digamos para la paz completa y
digamos evitar los efectos adversos de
Las Guerras por otro lado rápidamente
también una cuestión que nos ha
confirmado la cancillería de Venezuela
que ha sido su petición y es el rechazo
un ánimo a la aplicación de medidas
coercitivas unilaterales violatorias del
derecho internacional que impidan el
desarrollo de los estados Rosa Quiero
preguntarle por un hecho al margen de
esta Cumbre justo enfrente del centro de
convenciones donde tenía lugar este
encuentro una pequeña manifestación de
ciudadanos dominicanos que fue disipada
por la policía que reclamaban o qué
querían dar a conocer ante los
asistentes
pues Santiago De hecho estas escenas de
personas lo que querían era aprovechar
que la atención de la comunidad
internacional o al menos de la comunidad
iberoamericana está centrada aquí en
Santo Domingo para mostrar expresar su
descontento con a las políticas del
presidente Luis abinader pero también
por las consecuencias que tiene en
términos de aumento del costo de vida de
los productos básicos de escasez de
medicamentos o también de la política
represiva contra los que llaman sus
hermanos haitianos pero como bien lo
decías está estos manifestantes
denunciaban el acoso de la fuerza
pública Y es que finalmente Así ha sido
de hecho la Policía Militar nos ha
apartado de esta congregación para
dispersar enseguida a los manifestantes
con gases lacrimó